but we begin this half-hour with the
debate over classifying violence
committed against police officers as
hate crimes Texas is poised to join
Louisiana and Kentucky is the third
state to pass a so-called blue lives
matter law more than a dozen other
states have similar legislation pending
the laws call for harsher punishment for
those convicted of killing or assaulting
an officer but critics questioned
whether those laws are effective at
preventing violence at all don't need a
cop we'll travel to Texas to learn more
Toni good morning good morning the
latest numbers show violence against
police officers is indeed on the rise
and that's one reason why many people
back these proposals but others say hate
crime laws simply aren't meant to cover
men and women in blue when a sniper
opened fire in Dallas last July
Heidi Smith's husband Michael was one of
five officers killed just because he
wore the uniform he still came home to
us every night now Smith is afraid more
police will be targeted I was in
downtown Dallas going to an event with
my children I was scared the whole time
at night to be in a patrol car what were
you worried about someone walking up and
shooting us a hate crime
yes 135 officers were killed on duty in
2016
the highest total in five years of those
21 officers were ambushed the highest
total in more than two decades this is
the building this is El Centro the
College
that's why Texas State Representative
Jason vallabha introduced a bill to give
the blue uniform itself protection now
we're seeing attacks on police officers
based solely on one thing their status
as police officers and I think that's
what's important about this legislation
there are people who would say it
cheapens the category that hate crimes
are supposed to stop bigotry well I
think you can call the attacks that
we've seen against our police officers
clearly within the category of bigotry
when you attack a police officer merely
because they are doing their job we must
respond in the same way that we would
protect those who are of different color
Jeffery Robinson is a human rights
attorney with the American Civil
Liberties Union
he argues that crimes against police are
already well prosecuted in fact we have
supported as we should our law
enforcement officers so to suggest that
police officers should somehow be
protected by a hate crime is to
misunderstand what a hate crime is even
if every state in America protected
police officers as a group with hate
crime laws you don't think there'd be
any drop in killings against police
there'd be no drop in killings of police
whatsoever what that response does is to
ignore the reality you want to talk
about training culture and
accountability and changing those things
in policing that's going to be hard
that's going to take effort and people
don't like to talk about that but that's
where we are
Heidi Smith believes the legislation
will give police the protection they
need to do their job would it be a
validation of Mike's life to have this
bill farming's definitely and the other
four officers SLO and Texas governor
Greg Abbott is expected to sign the new
law in order to sign a new bill into law
but while many states move closer to
doing the same you know critics say the
only way to make police truly safer is
to improve relations with the community
it really calls into question the
definition of hatred and bigotry in this
it can be a hateful act and yet not a
hate crime don't need a couple thanks
very much